mais moi je suis extrêmement choqué par
ce qu'a dit Enrico Matias enfin Valérie
dégommé physiquement même s'il est reven
mais non mais c'est ça le débat dégomé
physiquement dégommé physiquement c'est
une provocation au crime je suis désolé
c'est répréhensible c'est condamnable là
il dit carrément il faut les éliminer
bien entendu que sur le non bien entendu
Valéri je partage tout je partage tout
sur l'indignation des actes barbares
commis en Isra sur le même plan c'est
scandaleux ce que tu
fais qui parle enfin mais qui parle
exusem excusez-moi je suigé en fait ce
qui me sidère c'est même d'en faire un
sujet on parle d'en Matias le mendant de
l'amour vous voulez en faire le mur de
la mort vous c'est de attendez une
phrase sortie une phrase bien sûr
qu'elle est choquante cette phrase qui
l'a dite dans quel contexte à quel
moment quel âge a-t-il c'est un moment
d'émotion pure de colère j'étais avec
lui 10 minutes avanter sur le plateau je
vous parler écoutez ce que je vous dire
écoutez ce que je vais vous dire il
était ému au larmes juste avant pourquoi
parce qu'il on a Mar de voir cette
espèce
d'agression exactement cette agression
incroyable il a découvert ses enfants
décapités ces femmes décapitées violé
laissez-moi aller au bout et donc il est
tellement ému il rentre sur le plateau
et il disent qu'il pense à 4 ans 24 ans
avec l'émotion et à 84 ans je vous
souhaite d'avoir ce genre d'émotion
parce que on compare une petite phrase
de rien du tout avec un parti la France
indigne qui ne reconnaît même pas le
caractère terroriste d'une attaque vous
voulez que je vous sorte les photos vous
voulez que je vous sorte les vidéos vous
allez voir que cette petite phrase qu'il
a sortie vous allez vite la ranger du
côté de votre tête pourquoi non mais
attendez là on est en train de faire un
faux
procès pas vous je dis à vous je dis à
tous ceux qui pensent oui et à tous les
spectateurs dire aut cette phrase
pourrait être choquante avec ve dire un
adversaire politique mais hrico Matias
qui est un homme d'émotion un homme qui
était en colère qui était au bord des
larmes je suis désolé mais ça vaut pas
le coup de lui en vouloir parce que
d'abord aujourd'hui ce dérapage il s'est
excusé alors que la France soumise n'a
pas dérapé ça a été écrit pensé assumé
ils n'ont pas voulu un reconnaître le
caractère antisémite terroriste ils ne
se sont pas excusés donc on a Enrico qui
s'excuse on a la secte mélanchoniste qui
ne s'excuse pas et vous mettez ça au
niveau du scandale excusez-moi mais
c'est scandaleux ce que vous
faites et c'est vrai que pour les
artistes c'est quand même hyper
compliqué parce que l' artiste il est
censé fédérer il est censé rassembler et
donc sans gouffrer féd
non je comprends la rétisence c'est ce
que j'allais dire c'est que on est
d'accord ou là oui mais c'est pour ça
qu'il faut savoir le faireendre la rétis
Philippe Lelouche VI réagir en direct
euh sur une chaîne 24 news Mélenchon est
une sale ordure et Louis Boyard est un
sinistre crétin et je serai ravi d'aller
au tribunal avec eux voilà donc c'est
voilà ça ça c'est un acte terroriste il
vont être traumatisé mélanch on va
refaire un tweet alors justement après
on voudrait des artistes aussi de
confession non juuives parce qu'en fait
c'est pas un truc que pour les Juifs en
fait c'est pas un attentat euh enfin je
veux dire il faudrait que tout le monde
s'en parle de ce sujet-là sinon je
trouve qu'il y a un truc qui est un peu
comment dire privé et qui me gêne moi et
communautaire et qui qui est un peu
choquant voilà c'est-à-dire bah ça veut
dire que c'est en fait c'est juste comme
le disait tout à l'heure Fran c'est
c'est les Juifs pour les Juifs alors que
c'est l'humanité entière c'est les
citoyens du monde entier qui devraient
se lever contre ce terrorisme là on
parle beaucoup de Kyan Mbappé hein parce
que c'est les deux qui reviennent le
plus c'est Kyan Mbappé et au marc
beaucoup de gens disent qu'ils n'ont pas
réagi qui réagissent à tout qui n'ont
pas réagi à ça comment vous expliquez ça
Gill verd bon Kyan Mbappé il joue au PSG
le PSG club du Qatar déjà c'est pas
facile politiquement et deuxièmement moi
je vais vous dire quelque chose Kyan
Mbappé il est suivi par des millions des
dizaines de millions de gens si il fait
un tweet comme tout le monde il va avoir
non pas 5 ou 10 si c'est nous mais 5
millions de messages mais il bloque les
commentaires
alorsir ma phrase ou j'explique il va
avoir 5 millions de message disant je ne
suis pas d'accord et cetera et Kyan
Mbappé ne veut pas ne peut pas se
permettre ça il a
peuris ce que ça veut dire que les
terroristes ont gagné ça veut dire que
les terroristes ont gagné parce qu'ils
empêch ils empêchent l'icône du foot
français l'icône du sport français de
pouvoir justener un mage de P Mo moi je
vais vous répondre aussi Mbappé je faut
pas oublier quelque chose je pense il y
a y a plein de gens je l'ai redit je
l'ai dit déjà hier il y a plein de gens
qui étaient à la rêve parti qui sont pas
qui sont pour la paix donc c'était des
innocents il y a même je pense il y a
beaucoup aussi également de personnes de
confession musulmanes qui ont été tués
je un
massacre chrétiens donc voilà donc ça a
été un massacre pour tout le mondechez
je vous dis il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent qu'est-ce qu'on fait voilà parce
que c'est moi je vous dis il y a plein
de gens aussi et de musulmans qui
m'écrivent et qui me disent Cyril on
condamne ce qui s'est passé on condam on
condamne ce qui s'est passé il y a des
fr fr à nous aussi qui sont morts et
aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup qui
disent aussi les Palestiniens sont aussi
victimes
Hamas il dis y en a qui vont se rrouver
sous les bombes à cause de ce qui s'est
passé je vous dire moi je vous dis je
discute avec mon père tout le temps qui
pour moi un sage voilà et qui est
vraiment pour la paix des peuples et qui
a un garçon qui essayé de faire le bien
toute sa vie et ben il me disait moi
voilà je suis extrêmement triste de de
ce qui s'est passé en Israël il est
dévasté je vous le dis forcément il voit
des images toute la journé est ma mère
aussi ils sont dévasté et mon père il a
plein d'amis Palestiniens musulmans et
il me dit je suis dévasté et je suis
aussi dévasté pour eux il me dit parce
que je suis dévasté par ce drame mais je
suis dévasté par ce qui va se passer
aussi derrière et ça il faut le dire
aussi c'est pas essayer de ménager la
chèvre et le chou les civils là là les
je vous dis quand on voit des enfants
égorgés comment comment on peut ne pas
condamner je suis désolé et et là et là
et là c'est vrai tout à l'heure j'étais
j'étais assez gentil avec avec eux avec
les Kilian Mbappé avec Léo Marcy et
cetera quand on voit des enfants égorgés
les mecs quand on a tweeté pour les
Ouigours c'est très bien il faut le
faire on en a a même reçu ici quand on a
tweeté pour tout tous les drames pour
pour l'Ukraine pour l'Ukraine il en a
plein qui ont tweté pour l'Ukraine fait
un post les gars il y a eu des enfants
qui ont été égorgés kan Mbappé je sais
pas sil me regarde ou ou Marcille qui en
plus j'aime beaucoup les deux voilà mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui un moment il
faut condamner ça parce que c'est
aujourd'hui il y a combien de
personnalités en France les 10 plus
grosses personnalités en France c'est
qui c'est kan Mbappé c'est Antoine
Dupond le capitaine pleine Coupe du
Monde c'est kan Mbappé c'est Marc c'est
c'est qui c'est a 10 il en a
10anjaces Goldman voilà c'est tout mais
il y en a pas 50 aujourd'hui il y a 10
artistes importants 10 voix importantes
en France on va pas se mentir il y a
quoi il y a 10 VO qui portent en
télévision aujourd'hui il a voilà
j'adore Denis Brognard mais bon Denis
Brognard voilà on sa qui TW pas
jardin vousêes exprimé non mais voilà
après voilà mais après moi moi je vous
dis la vérité je je je me suis je suis
obligé de m'exprimer j'ai aucun mérite
aujourd'hui j'ai une tribune tous les
soirs je vais pas parler du gars qui a
voilà je pas ne pas parler de ça voilà
oui encore une fois on va dire c'est un
juif qui parle des Juifs ce n'est pas
l'histoire des Juifs là là c'est
l'histoire de l'humanité dire que là ça
touche à l'humain comment on peut rester
inst ible à cette histoire là ça touche
nos cœurs c'est-à-dire que on dit des
mots on dit des mots en l'air une femme
une femme qu' qu'on a vu tirée par les
cheveux brûlé un bébé égorgé c'est des
mots essayez fermez les yeux 2 secondes
et et et entendez ces mots et
visualiseer ce que ça veut dire donc
quand vous dites ça à un moment pourquoi
comment vous ne prenez pas immédiatement
votre plume votre téléphone pour dire je
suis contre la
barbarie c'est pas politique c'est pas
machin c'est je cont Barb est-ce qu'il y
a des acteurs qui ont réagi des acteurs
très connu sa pas les plus grands
acteurs non juifs non non juif non mais
il y aurait eu la même chose dans un
pays je sais pas moi l'Italie l'Espagne
aurait mis pr Italie pourquoi pourquoi
et parlons des musulmans aussi parce que
je rappelle quand même tout utile que
plus de 91 % des victimes d'attentat
terroristes islamistes sont des
musulmans bien sûr donc la logique
voudrait que les musulmans soent les
premierers en tête à dire non ramasse
puisque les ramass tu tout le monde mais
ça c'est important aussi
el est pas réagiamel de je sais pas on
va regarder on va demander en siamel a
réagi regarder Gilbert Montag a réagi
regardez comment peut-on encore en
2023 arriver à un taux de de de barbarie
tel comment les êtres peuvent-ils être
habités du mal à ce point aussi à mes
amis
musulmans j'ai la chance qu'il font
partie de mon public et je vourais leur
dire n'ayez pas peur de vous exprimer
n'ayez pas peur de montrer votre bonté
n'ayez pas peur de dire que ces gens-là
le ramass font honte à votre religion à
qui vous êtes parce que vous nêtes pas
comme ça c'est pas possible je vous
embrasseors
parfait par rapport au non réaction de
beaucoup de musulmans moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que parlait deam
qu'on
non mais vous l'exliquez hier sur les
réseaux c'est beaucoup plus clivé que
par exemple sur ce plateau et cetera et
il y a beaucoup de musulmans qui se
disent maintenant il y a eu un acte de
barbarie mais attention au peuple
palestinien on espère qu'Israël ne va
pas
massacrer je justifie pas laissez-moi
justeir ma je ne justifie pas j'essaie
juste de vous
expliquera s'il vous plaî pas t même
temps énormément de musul ne réagissent
pas pour cette raisonsl et qui se disent
maintenant attention Israël ne doit pas
massacrer le peuple palestinien mais
c'est vrai les musulmans se disent pas
le cacher voilà c'est
vrai ou tu es parfaitement hypocrite que
je nespère pas ou alors tu es tu vis
dans un monde angélique de bisounours
parce que toi tu es en train de dire que
la France est partagé entre ceux qui
condamn ouvertement ceux qui condamn
mais qui disent de rien et puis ceux qui
disent on condne pas parce qu'il va
avoir d'autres il a aussi des gens qui
soutiennent
ce